scientists have discovered a few big
cats in captivity have an obsession for
well-known men's cologne a study
conducted at the Wildlife Conservation
Society's Bronx Zoo indicated that among
a number of perfumes and colognes tested
Calvin Klein's obsession for men was the
top choice of interest to the two
cheetahs at the zoo other fragrances
were tested with some other big cats at
the zoo Tom would encourage us really
powerful
cheek rubbing behavior where these big
cats would literally wrap their paws
around a tree and just vigorously rub up
and down sometimes they would start
drooling their eyes would have closed
almost like they were going into a
chance and they would uh you know spend
minutes rubbing up against an object
that we had sprayed with certain
perfumes colognes
we knew that cats would respond to
various perfumes and colognes because
it's it's sort of in zoo lore we've
known about that for years smell is an
important sense for all cat species an
investigating sense is common especially
those in an artificial setting which
lacks the variety of new and old sense
found in a natural environment big cats
engage in cheek rubbing behavior to
either deposit scent or pick up sense
from other cats there's very likely a
territorial component to that enabling
them to mark territories and there's
some evidence that they're also picking
up reproductive keys from members of the
opposite sex
WCS researchers conducted testing at
zoos with Tigers and later with cheetahs
man-made and natural scents are used as
olfactory enrichment tools at the zoo
the scents are sprayed inside animals
enclosures to keep the animals active
and engaged both for their mental and
physical well-being and for the viewing
public spin afib but it could also be
used to aid in field research you can
apply sense to camera traps to induce
that the target animals that you're
looking to photograph close to cameras
so that you can begin to get an idea of
what species are in a habitat that
you're studying in the wild WCS says its
researchers deployed obsession for men
and other fragrances at camera traps in
Guatemala they say it has enabled them
to get more precise estimates of Jaguar
populations in one of the most important
Jaguar refuges in the Americas the Maya
biosphere reserve perfume companies very
closely god their ingredients and
formulas so we don't really know what's
in a given perfume the knowledge about
wild animals interest in scent has also
been used in setting up hair traps where
scientists can collect hair follicles
from some species of wild cats for DNA
research when the animals rub tree bark
for example they leave behind hair which
scientists can use to extract DNA from
the hair follicles to identify diversity
in the animals population loss of
habitat due to human agriculture and
development and illegal killings has
caused several Wildcat species to become
endangered Thomas is mindful that some
people could misuse this knowledge about
sense but he pointed out that obsession
for men was not the best-performing
fragrance in the field and declined to
reveal which perfumes or colognes were
the best lures for all cats in the wild
in fact a similar experiment conducted
in the wild found that big cats did not
express much interest in the sense
offered
you